okay okay take it away all right
wonderful wonderful
um so um
I have to uh uh give a an excuse this is
this is you know this is a hollow ground
with many famous formulas being written
on this whiteboard and so
Shafi said it's the end of the workshop
people are fried
entertain them with some pixels
and that's that's what I'm gonna do
there's also going to be a story uh the
story will have nothing to do with with
with the
um with uh animal communication uh but
maybe just maybe there might be
something that that that you guys can
take from my experience in computer
vision and uh and maybe it will click
something let's hope if not then just
enjoy the pixels okay
okay so um
I did my PhD in computer vision and uh
this was you know more than 20 years ago
and and the world was very very
different you know I I had more hair but
also
um
the the way that that that we did our
work was
not really very focused on on the data
in fact the typical cvpr joke of the
time was you know if your paper has one
image it's a hack but if it has two
images it's an algorithm and if it has
three images oh it's a framework
um
so really and you know in in this in in
communities learning communities like
like Europe's for example this was even
more so that the the primary thing was
the learning algorithm the learning
algorithm was the key that's what you
come up with this brilliant idea this is
what your your advisor will be happy for
you and then you write it all up and you
work on it for half a year and then
maybe uh you know a week before the
deadline you you add some you know use
some features and then maybe the night
before the deadline is okay yeah I need
to run it on some data some you know you
UCI mushrooms if everybody anyone
remembers that right something right it
doesn't really matter okay so data
really got no respect okay and
fundamentally I think this was always
wrong but I think it took our field a
very very too long a time to to
appreciate uh because the signs were
already there
um so this is uh this is a this is a an
example uh from maybe some of you have
taken a computer vision class maybe
um so you might remember this the first
time the first time that that face
recognition actually worked you know
there was a time it didn't work at all
and then boom suddenly it started
working and then the next few years it
was in all the cameras and just big
success story
can anyone who took a machine or
computer vision a Machine Vision class
remember what was the paper that made
that big leap yes
thank you ah wonderful in
huh
sorry yes yes sir phase detection yes
that's correct okay that's correct
that's what everyone remembers the old
intros but actually
it wasn't the first and it wasn't the
best
there was a set of papers that came out
basically around the same time
um that just started working okay and uh
the first one was rally Balu Ji kanadi
uh the second one was the third one was
Yola Jones
was the first chairman kanadi was the
best villain Jones was real time okay
but by the time but that time China
Kennedy was also real time so that's not
really the reason what is the reason
that everybody remembers villagers look
at this
the features that rally used were pixels
boring and the classified oh my God
neural networks is so 80s that was just
old school like nobody wanted to hear
anything about neural networks in the
90s because it was just really old
school Cheyenne canadi okay features
were a little bit better pairs of wavel
coefficients but naive Bayes so naive ah
Viola Jones Okay features were hard
pretty good but classified was this
boosted Cascade at this beautiful
algorithm absolutely gorgeous I still
teach it in in the machine learning
class because it is a beautiful
algorithm
but guess what completely different
features completely different algorithms
pretty much the same performance
so why do you know what was actually the
unifying theme between those papers that
made them work
data set it was the fact that they were
the first ones to realize oh
maybe not we shouldn't just use positive
data or faces maybe we should also use
data with no faces negative data that
was what all these papers had in common
but somehow in our field that did not
that did not get recorded that that
simple idea did not actually get
recorded
why well because unfortunately
there is this scientific narcissism you
know we we will love to give credit
to our own cleverness because you know
data is out there data is just physics
just slaying around like it's it's not
fair to give credit to creditors to our
cleverness
and I'm going to try to convince you
that this has actually been kind of
setting us back for a while and we
should we should we should basically
become a little bit more humble okay
um and there is there is a wonderful
paper it's it's quite old by now but I
think it's still quite relevant well
there are reasonable effectiveness of
data uh from folks from Google and uh
it's basically the argument is that you
know parts of the world are explained by
elegant mathematics physics chemistry
astronomy and we have done really really
well in all of those that we have we
have really made great progress but some
Fields it's really really hard to
explain it by by elegant mathematics
psychology genetics economics
Linguistics
there's a difference between saying it's
hard and saying it cannot no no that's
right that's right it's
it hasn't had hasn't happened yet let's
put it that way okay uh they I think
they do say they cannot they they take
it more argue yeah they take a strong
argument I'd say it hasn't happened yet
and and this is what they argue this is
where the magic of data comes in uh and
because you know some things are just
messy and
the closer you get to kind of
evolutionary things the Messier it yes
you know if if you're in the world of
physics you know things are good if
you're in a world in in in biology then
then the entropy gets really hot right
so like you take something like a Navy
or Stokes equation and it's a very very
complex process so this is like a
computer graphics person and me talking
you know rendering this beautiful smoke
okay it's not the easy but it's actually
mathematically it's you know it's just
the navier Stokes equation and you just
need to you know run it the right way
and then you get this beautiful
beautiful smoke
but try rendering the bark of of this
tree
very very hard it's an extremely hard
problem even now in video games you know
the these kind of things like natural
things like bar countries doesn't really
quite look realistic why because there
is just way more parameters here because
the appearance of this bark of the
street depended on you know the Genome
of the tree all the entropy of of the
evolution of that tree plus whether you
know squirrels live there which latitude
longitude the tree was you know what
were the what were the weather
conditions before right there is just
lots and lots of
data that goes into this appearance and
so it's not as easy as you know picking
a few parameters to get it to the other
tip okay
and even you know defining things like
things like a tree is is it turns out to
be pretty hard right so you know brown
trout moving upwards and branching with
leaves okay that's that's not quite
that's not quite gonna gonna gonna fit
it's gonna fit many other things that
are not trees and it's also not going to
explain some of the tricks and and you
know if you want a a longer visual
version of this uh Wittgenstein has a
whole fetus on this and uh and Eleanor
rosh actually here in Berkeley also
wrote a lot about about this issue right
uh and yet even though there is no good
definition of something like a tree
every three-year-old can can tell you a
tree from a nut tree right because
because of the data okay
and and the nice thing is of course that
now we have this Deluge updating man in
fact we have it for a while so even
while this has been a problem and the
facts that we just did not have the data
now things are changing okay
um and what we have seen you know maybe
even uh starting 20 years ago some of
work I did and also Antonio my my dear
colleague uh um was showing that if you
have enough data then some really really
dumb algorithms
could work surprisingly well okay so
this is actually a paper from Antonio
who I I understand couldn't make it but
don't you worry he is here in in in in
in essence uh this is uh this is this is
something something that that they did
really really early on 2008 okay wait
wait you know a lot of other efforts
like imagenet basically Antonio asked
and co-workers
how many images does a five-year-old see
and they came up with a number that's
big but it's not that big 80 million
even in 2007 you could actually deal
with 80 million images now the only
trick is that you couldn't store them in
high resolution you've had to store a
smaller resolution so they realize that
actually if you store them 32 by 32
pixels you actually get a lot of the
information in there and so this was a
data set of
of 80 million 30 by 32 images for those
of you in machine learning maybe you
remember cfar C vartel c4500 this is
that is just a tiny sliver that they
scrape from that data set yes but the
tiny images it's something about it it's
actually a feature because of the small
size uh the the nearest neighbor problem
doesn't Suffer Well yeah that is true
that is true that is true it was yeah I
mean it I would still love to have them
bigger because you can always make them
small in fact that uh that phase the
phase detection algorithm the first
thing they would do is that actually
make those images smaller because that
then it would actually work better so I
would have still liked it to be higher
resolution but but but you're you're
right that actually reducing the
dimensionality often is is helpful to
you
any other I I do want to have this
interactive so please please retract
and and then
the kind of magic started to come to
have so this is this is just examples of
uh of
a few images
this is
three images and these are their nearest
neighbors the closest images in in L2
sense I think L2 uh to those and then
what you can see is that you know if you
have like 8 000 images you already get
like most of these are humans and those
of these are like outdoor seeds but as
you get more and more data they just get
closer and closer and closer
right there's this kind of
post-modernist
sense that you know all the images
actually already have been captured you
just need to find it and and
um and you know they they were able to
they they had before imagenet they had
mapped this to wordnet and so they could
actually use those nearest neighbors to
get you kind of a ward net hierarchy and
explain an image in terms of the labels
of the of the ordnet hierarchy
um and even without any annotations they
had these beautiful results where for
example for polarization so you give the
system a black and white image
and it's polarizes for you and the way
it does it it basically takes I think
like 9 or 15 nearest neighbors and
averages their own
and you can see that it's it's it's
doing it in a very data driven way
because this guy colorized correctly but
this guy did not because there is just
not enough data that is upside down so
this did not give you the right signal
but this this did okay
and and again this is like this is the
simplest algorithm in in the machine
learning textbook this is nearest
neighbor right which of course is not
that bad covert heart says that it's
it's it's very close to to base risk so
so it's not it's not bad but it's it's a
very simple Outlook sorry yes um okay uh
can you
um I think I understand what a nearest
neighbor is based on context but I think
I'm interested in understanding how
human programs and thresholds for what
counts as a nearest neighbor dearest
Nate right so nearest neighbor is the
club you you have a a set of points and
dimensions
and then you for your query point so
this is let's say your query point
you find the closest point in something
like L2 distance
euclidean distance for example that's
the simplest one there are other
distances you can use but the L2
distances is the simplest one that that
was mostly believed so this is nearest
name it's the first algorithm you are
taught in a machine learning class and I
claim that it's still the best there is
also a little bit better version where
it's called K nearest neighbors where
you take instead of the first the
closest person the thing you take K
close to Six and that then you average
the the the the labels of those key
closest things and that works even
better that's actually as good as basis
you cannot do better than K nearest
neighbor under various assumptions of
things going to Infinity
okay
yes
yes all right
so at the around the same time I was
also very keen on on trying to see how
far we can go with data but I like
bigger images so I was thinking okay how
about wholesaling so you have a image
took it in Switzerland but I want to get
rid of this Castle want to fill it in
fill in this hole what do I do the same
thing we downloaded only two million
images from the internet here
and basically again the nearest neighbor
and then a little bit of computer
graphics and voila it it it it does okay
and you know you can have second nearest
neighbor third nearest neighbor and
sometimes it doesn't quite worry but you
know
um you can you know reduce get rid of
the the view from your
to get a better view from your window
you can get rid of all this build up on
your favorite Beach
etc etc and so why does it work
and here the thing is the story of this
paper was that you know this was this
was 2007 so again nobody or the biggest
data set was like uh 10 000 images right
and so we downloaded 20 000 images in
the beginning
and uh my then student James Hayes said
okay it's not working so these are the
nearest neighbors or for
for this image and they are not really
very near okay and so he was like okay
you know what it's Christmas we're
probably not going to make this but I'll
just keep downloading over the Christmas
break
and then
when we came back in early January we
had 2 million and exactly the same
algorithm the same nearest neighbor
algorithm that we did before suddenly
the neighbors became much much nearer so
it is indeed that sometimes
you know when you have enough data you
know it starts Whispering into your ear
and this is not it's lots of data is
good but as as we all know you know this
is a very high dimensional space so no
matter how much you download you know 2
million is really not that much uh there
is other things that are going to help
us out uh here is an image and I want to
get rid of the screen okay so I get rid
of the screen now I need to fill it in
and it does very well let's look under
the hood to see what's happening here is
the nearest neighbors here is the first
nearest neighbor the closest image so
look at this
this is a different River a different
city
okay
but you know we have two things going
for us thing number one
we as tourists are very boring you know
I crossed the street or across the sand
and I turn right oh what a beautiful
view say I and ten ten thousand other
American tourists right so we are biased
in the kind of date pictures that we
take
also
you know
European Architects are also maybe don't
have that much in imagination because oh
you have a river let's let's Bank it up
with granite and let's have some uh you
know uh high buildings on on the side
because we want to have them we have
they all want to have a nice uh views
from into the river right so those two
things make the problem actually not as
terrifying as as it as it could have
been because the distribution of of
these photographs on the Internet is
actually
lives on a on a on a lower dimensional
space than one would have thought okay
and and this is why it works later on we
um the next year James and I also apply
this to this cute probably were called
M2 GPS so you give it a give us an image
and and and again we'd you know had by
that time we got six million images and
they all had GPS tags and again we just
did nearest Neighbors
and voila it could basically geolocate
our query image
not not badly I mean it wasn't it wasn't
like perfect it wasn't uh you know CAA
equality but it was it was not bad okay
and this is again this is 2008.
um interestingly enough
fast forward 15 million years yes
there's something so like thinking about
this like learning there's something uh
not satisfying because it's memorizing
and not generalizing in a way or are you
saying there's nothing left to
generalize too these are all the images
that anyone could possibly take
yeah and look so I would love
to be generalizing absolutely
generalization is a very hard problem
I think where I'm going with here is
that
when we think something is generalizing
we need to really look carefully whether
it's not just memories
and how much is generalized okay
because over and over we have been
would have been kind of whipped by this
we think that we are generalizing but
actually
it turns out
speaking of which 15 minutes 15 years
later
uh neural networks come in okay and the
Google folks decide that they wanna they
wanna repeat this task
uh with a big neural network and you've
got to give them you know the name is
great the the paper title is fantastic
okay
um and it worked much much better okay
but they changed two things
instead of nearest neighbors they had a
neural network I think BGG at that point
or maybe inceptionet but also because
they're Google they have they had like
an order of magnet more date okay
unlucky for them I was the reviewer and
I said no no no no no no you need to
have an apple to Apple comparison here
you need to see how well how much is it
the data and how much is it algorithm
and guess what
so this is this is into GPS this is
James Hayes's hand tuned features and
this is fancy schmancy Google lots and
lots of parameter neural network
and
it's not doing amazingly bit better it's
it's better in some regimes it's worse
than other regions okay
again
we have to be very careful
to make sure that we know where the the
performance is coming from yes I thought
you were going to make them do nearest
Neighbors on 91 million I mean that
would be even better but they did not I
mean I tell I tell them Apple samples
they presumably just decided to do the
easiest thing but yeah it would have
been even nicer to to do it the other
way yes have you tried uh no no I that
that I think it's still
only because the the the the bad thing
about nearest neighbors is that you like
it you really have to linearly go for
all of your data every single time so it
it it's it's very expensive very
expensive so I'm not saying people
should drop their neural networks and
switch the nearest neighbor what I'm
saying is that under the hood it's very
expensive in other measures right
no it's not it's not a practical method
but it's a very good
it's a very good Baseline it's a very
good base life especially if you feel
like you're generalizing
maybe you should just double check that
you really are doing
better yeah
okay
so the good news really stupid
algorithms for lots of data gets you
this unreasonable Effectiveness okay
um but given the whole biological tilt
of this Workshop
surely surely for brain can does not not
going to remember uh you know 80 million
things
surely well here I'm I'm gonna show some
slides that my dear friend or Oliver uh
LED it to me and this is a some very old
work she doesn't show with us anymore
but I think I think it needs to be known
because it's such a brilliant piece of
work
um
she asked the question of what is the
capacity of long-term memory how much do
humans actually remember vision
right and what you know what we knew
before that point was starting by
standing who actually showed that that
that capacity seemed to be pretty good
basically he showed the subject's 10 000
images and they were able to recall if
they seen this image or not 83 of the
time which was very surprising okay
but
um it wasn't quite clear
how much were they remembering because
the images are very very different right
one was a BH rather was a kitchen so
there was it it could have probably been
enough to just remember like a couple of
words about the image you didn't really
need to remember all the details so it
wasn't clear how much actual uh bits of
data was remembered okay and so this is
where AUD said okay I'm gonna do a
another experiment but I'm going to do
it on harder data I'm gonna do it on
data where you have
completely different objects so this is
basically matching the standing
experiment
different examples of the same kind of
object
and different states of the same object
instance
okay
and
what is amazing because she actually put
the experiment on a slide deck and we
are all going to do it now
you know a real experimental here but
it's really
once you do it you will really
understand okay so
basically the task is
uh you need to detect repeats when
something happens when something is seen
again
you have to detect so you're going to be
clapping
you're gonna clap if you see something
again okay
okay are we ready
okay it's gonna go fast so be ready to
watch okay okay let's do it
laughs
[Laughter]
huh
foreign
six hours but I think you're starting to
get an idea then at the end
uh she would actually ask these binary
questions which one did you see A or B
very good which one did you see
very good which one do you see
okay
and it's magic
okay so the results are
so she replicated standing in fact she
got a little bit even higher performance
than sending it but I think within the
within more or less within air bars but
this but what about different examples
and so odd asked all of her psychology
colleagues what would you expect it's
going to be you know
chance it's going to be you know the
same it's going to be half the
performance uh and um well now that you
did the task what what do you think what
is going to be here what's going to be
here what's going to be here how how are
the two are the bars gonna go so
probably high in the example sorry sorry
sorry
didn't yeah sorry
basically it was almost the same
right which was an absolutely magical
route so how many people have seen this
result before come on
okay so I'm I think it's good that I'm
showing this because I think this is
need to be known yes
so just to clarify so the question is
how much can we memorize if we are shown
something for a short time or is the
question more General than that
I mean this is a very very specific
question
can you tell if you have seen something
before but standing so they had to
experiment by standing this is the same
the same procedure yeah okay because I
was thinking like Chinese people
memorize thousands and thousands of
um
to the tiny details there's an
individual scroll that's right well we
all do we you guys just did yes yes
absolutely
um it's it's it's a little bit tricky so
there is some follow-up work when you
ask people to actually draw what you
have what you remember and that is turns
out to be a much harder task than to
tell if I have seen it before okay so so
these things are are somewhat different
but
but I find this really really impressive
so that's really informed a whole bunch
of the work I do when I when I saw this
Rhythm because this is I think this is
very uh yes
sorry I don't see one that's why I do
computer vision so you have to just show
them if you have any knowledge of
whether this is
sense specific that is to say has anyone
done this with touch or with smell or
with hearing
a good question
um I I mean I know that for for for like
for for semantics for words I think it's
it's much worse
I don't think anyone has done it for
other senses you can email odd and ask
or somebody should do it if not because
that sounds like a great idea yes
um I as a vision person you know half
the brain is doing Vision so I would
like to say that there's more parameters
devoted to visual data so I want to see
that we are you know visual vision is
special in this case but I don't
actually know I I don't know yeah I'm
really hopeful that it's the same it's
just a sign of different modalities
because I got to tell you
[Music]
I would have clapped like once
I
I couldn't do this to happen oh
interesting interesting
yeah so I mean these are all these are
all
you know I'm you know that you could do
it with sequence of audio though I'm
really hopeful because otherwise I
better be or maybe you were just not
paying attention you know after the end
of the day
there's one more chance because
natural question here is wait do people
have photographic memory and for this
all I did a follow-up study that for
some reason they didn't even publish but
I think this is even better study okay
um what they did is they generated uh
synthetic textures with the first and
second order statistics of of uh uh
waiver coefficients to match natural
image statistics okay so something like
this
okay and then they run the same study
including these images okay
so let's do this this one is short okay
[Applause]
thank you
all right so as as you can sense it's
it's basically the textures are pretty
much a chance so it's not about us
remembering every single Pixel it's more
interesting than that we are remembering
something that is on want to learn
natural manifold okay
um so yeah I I think this is this is
really cool stuff so if you see odd
Oliver at some point tell her that you
saw this and she needs to publish this
yeah I'm not sure that I'm getting
correctly in the details but basically
what you said is that it's difficult for
people in images to remember the details
so they would say that I've seen the
image but not the details I think with
words is actually the opposite and there
was I think the study study in the
Soviet Union in the 60s where people had
a hard time to remember if they sell the
word in the sequence but if you gave a
definition they would remember that so
which is an opposite well we know but I
think what I'm saying here is not that
we are we don't remember the details
it's not about the details in fact
remember how there were two uh um TV
remotes
right that were very very different very
very similar but you guys
very directly pick the one that you've
seen before so the differences were very
minute and still you guys remembered
very well here it's not about the
details it's about these things being
not on the manifold of natural images
they were not something that you
perceive to be
sample from the from the natural visual
quality passed you have you seen a
remote I don't think that you would
remember that
sorry if the question was have you seen
a remote rather than showing a picture
or two pictures right so you're probably
across modality I think yeah I think
this is happening on the visceral level
it's like uh it's like a rasco painting
you know you remember a rasco painting
but there is no way you can describe
right so so I think there is actually no
yeah it doesn't actually connect very
well yeah other questions yes so to the
I mean to the point about the manifold
of natural images which I think is
related to the generalization thing
before these are also like real
photographs right and if you know the
original example was dogs playing uh
cards and you can imagine lots of wait
so the entire no no no nothing so sorry
the real the things that people can't
recognize uh are all images of
situations that actually you know
objects that actually exist situations
that actually occurred
um
but there's this sort of intermediate
category of things you know that are
like Dolly paintings or
um
you know whatever dogs playing cards
that
have natural image statistics they're
probably a higher order than this but
also would never actually occur in
practice and have no nearest Neighbors
in any training set so what does it mean
to be yeah so that yeah we'll we'll
we'll get there there is
Things Are
there is indeed something about
we are able to do some sort of a
compositional generalization because
presumably those things are even more
memorable than uh somewhere in the beach
yes yes
um so but I think what this again I you
know I'm Ohad does not have any argument
what this means and I'm not trying to
say that I know what this means but to
me what this means is that
things that we remember seem to be at
least made up of things that we are
familiar with whereas here it is really
not
it's not easy to see what are even the
parts that are that are familiar yeah I
think also not so familiar but also
depend on
you know nobody shows you a bunch of
soil textures and so your mom doesn't
show that the parents don't show you
though
in fact in fact you know people who are
let's say experts in mushrooms or you
know experts in uh in in some you know
geological Rock patterns they actually
are able to to recognize different parts
that that non-experts cannot so this is
this is definitely a trainable
absolutely a trainable skill so I'm sure
we can train some undergraduates of
these things
but
still it's interesting that
the untrained mind is basically allowing
it to stick away as I was looking at
this in kind of introspection as I was
looking at these pictures like I
immediately I recall the you know I
think it's multi-modality at play here
because
I heard words as I said pictures inside
whereas with these I can't I mean even
if the remote they're similar but you
can say okay your remote that looks like
there's a remote looks like that here I
cannot even describe stuff so I think I
think the lack of multimodality I mean
the lack of language recall that I have
here I think I mean probably interferes
with my results
I I I'm not sure there is death there is
some study similar size for pigeons
pigeons are also very good at this stuff
so I'm I wouldn't say oh it's a link
yeah yeah just okay so in the cycle in
the world of psychology I mean the
studies have been done about encoding
and how most people encode right so
visual is what we normally do we get
pictures of things except for things
that are more ambiguous like this yeah
and I was wondering if you were trying
if you were hearing the words for that
because we have such limits on the how
the number of words we can remember and
if you're trying to do if you're
encoding you weren't hearing words
though there's like there's just all
these pictures and then like people are
classic and I'm like I don't know
I mean yeah the seven plus or minus two
is is much much narrower than the visual
benefits so so the argument that you are
saying is a naturalness overseas
rather than anything you have to have
seen at least parts of it you're
argument for chunking yeah
so since we're talking a lot about
localization in this workshop and
there's anybody's done study about the
sort of naturalness versus like
doing this type of stuff with language
versus or with sounds that are familiar
to US versus you know
I can sort of answer a related thing
there's a guy at MIT Josh McDermott who
was once in uh a vision lab like a
psychology Vision lab who then stole
many techniques from from vision and
took them into the audio realm and and I
know one of the things he did was he
proved that
um repetition in audio uh after as few
as three but by five repetitions of
something and where it's overlapped with
other sounds we by five repetitions we
have it and they he did a thing similar
to this where degenerated artificial
sounds that had certain statistics which
were similar to
um
natural sounds but which had never been
natural sounds and so these showed that
just repetition of the thing a few times
even when it's mixed and overlapped with
other sounds is sufficient for us to
extract it as a chunk and like
now that's a thing for you
so that's the closest study I can think
of to this I was hoping so
um
had a few follow-up studies on
memorabilities which is basically how
well do you memorize different instances
and they do show that you know you you
know the the the Landscapes are
memorized worse than the objects and
faces but they did one study and I don't
remember the paper I don't have that
here yeah on on doing the same words
memorable versus forgettable words
because it turns out that there is also
there are some words that are more
memorable in fact what was wanted to do
a startup where she would basically
replace it in your email the common
words with a more memorable words so
that you know your resume or your email
with with the you know that the the
professor would reply to you more more
likely
um so there you look for Isola Oliver
memorability
language and that I think you should
find that paper
there's also like like Exemplar
Linguistics and there's like these
results I forget they're from but things
that like like people have very good
memories like the gender of the last
person they heard a word from even like
if that's not something that you would
think you would a dog so there is kind
of like Exemplar like studies in
linguistics a lot and I think people
there's people who really believe in
that stuff I forget who did those like
gender studies but it's really
interesting
going way out early here but this is for
for both
um I wonder if there's some notion of
like consonants versus dissonance and
how I might remember something for
example I remember the opening measures
of purple A's with that uh you know with
the tritone pretty much but
um
so I think like yeah like the the atonal
music it's impossible to memorize
because it is both the you know the
manifold of Master music right is that
when they were talking about sort of I
mean it immediately recognize it right
maybe I don't memorize the particular
pitches but I immediately recognize
something that's causative discipline
don't lazy I see it
yeah I mean the same way as
if we ever get there we talk about you
know generating images it's very easy to
to uh
to tell if okay something doesn't look
like a natural image very hard for the
computer by the way but very easy for us
and yeah it's it's I think it's kind of
the same thing
okay
but I'm not like you know we don't have
to I don't have to rush for anything as
long as you guys are having fun I'm your
I'm Your Entertainment
um okay so yes
um
so
you know on one hand
you know nearest neighbor data-driven
methods memorization
seem to be a large part of what's going
on
on the other hand of course you know
Roman memorization if you just really
like try to look up what from the data
set what you have seen before you know
that's not gonna work for a lot of
issues there are a lot of cases for
example you know long tails relative
events right you know we are as humans
are able to deal with events that that
are rare that we haven't really had the
data for we're still able to do it right
uh so it's kind of this idea of
disentanglement disentangling uh
different parts of of our stimulus into
into chunks that are that are familiar
to us uh and compositionality which is
when you can recompose them back back in
in ways that you haven't before right
and
and of course the the latest generative
model uh uh craze is really because
things are starting to change and it
seems like we are now getting a little
bit of a whiff of of disentanglement and
compositionality from some of these uh
new genitive models and and the text
models as well but again I'm a visual
person so I'm going to talk mostly about
the the visual stuff okay
um
so I'm sure everybody has seen this
here is some dolphin for you dolphin is
an astronaut suit on Saturn okay
um and and and and and it's it's quite
impressive because this is definitely
something that has never been in any of
the trainings
good question we'll get back to that but
but unlikely
um this one is is is is is particularly
uh uh like happy with this is Dali uh as
used by by a wonderful local artist
Danielle Baskin uh and you know they
they were planning to to take BART all
the way to Marin and that of course
never happened but this is dalism
Imagination of what it could have been
like to take the train across the Golden
Gate Bridge
um and to me it's a really really
impressive that that it it's able to
merge together things that it has really
not not seen before in in in a very
natural way that that that's you know I
I find this quite impressive
but again
I'm a little worried because everybody
saw like Dolly this Dali that stable
diffusion this cell division that we're
always talking about amazing algorithm
and then
you know fancy language language this
clip that and then yeah yeah there's
some data also sure
um
so let's do our evaluation here again
so here is a prompt squirrel reaching
for a nut these are three different
approaches
can tell can somebody guess which one
can you recognize any of those
approaches so this is three different
algorithms using the same prompt
all right yeah am I supposed to say like
nearest neighbor versus no they are all
genitive models that but they're all
different regenerative models
different underlying like is one of
diffusion and one's uh like a televised
language model yeah okay I'll buy it uh
to the left
I'm going to say it's a diffusion model
the middle one tokenized language model
the right one because you're just trying
to fool us as a nearest neighbor oh no
no the right one's got a weird distorted
thing I want this I want this so I'm
going to say that's a Style again that's
again this one yeah I'm gonna say the
thing on the right is again the thing on
the left is is uh I'm gonna say a
tokenized uh language model okay and the
one in the middle is there to pull this
is the tokenized one yeah and the one in
the middle is there to fool me because
it was actually a nearest neighbor that
you threw into to I see yeah okay I have
a different I think the right one is
Fusion all right one is the fusion
okay and the other two what can I choose
from okay okay the the choices are uh
basically a sequential model diffusion
type model and uh Gan model
middle one again okay
and you said that the right one was
again
all right are you ready for the answer
okay Dolly this is this is a sequential
model basically llm where which spits
out pixels instead of words and uh and
the latest Yan that so again diffusion
and language yeah so you were you you
got hundred percent see you know it's
multi-model yeah
the point the point I'm trying to make
here
is the very very different models right
extremely different
but it's not obvious
that you could tell one from the other
right
and in fact this is a slide form from my
former student desang Park who who did
the the gig again which brought Gans
back into competition
um
it's the number of parameters basically
the capacity for data so now the the
young kids they don't look at the data
they look at the number of parameters
but it's basically the same thing
because it's the capacity for the data
right it's like you know in years
neighbor it's one and the same right
your size of the data set is your
capacity when you have a parametric
model then it's really how many
parameters you have but it's still it's
a function of data because you keep on
increasing it until if you run out of
data right and so the bigger your model
the better your image quality this is
now one is is better okay and so you can
see that
the different methods here are basically
all fitting that pattern so like the the
the the the the
sequential model that has smaller
parameters actually not so good and the
sequential model that has more
parameters is doing actually very good
okay
so once again
we might be getting too married to a
particular you know algorithm
uh and not not remembering this lesson
again that
we need to look at the amount of data
and of course the quality of data
um
and the fact
that there is some really cool
generalization there is some really cool
compositionality there is some really
cool disentanglement but
there is also
you know a lot of kind of nearest
neighbor-like Behavior so this is a
synthetic image I think something about
uh uh Lighthouse I forgot the prompt
here Lighthouse and a stormy night and
we have a method of basically to trying
to find some of the real images from the
training set
uh that that you know that that are
similar and and you can see that there
is you know very very similar things
there's still definitely some
some by parts compositionality that's
happening but it's not like whom
complete magic right it's like it's not
un it's not maybe super surprising that
if given you know pages and pages of
these
uh you know you can concoct something
like that yes so I don't know well
probably it has been done but an
interesting experiment so if you
generate using one of these models a
training set and then you'll continue
training on so basically there will be
some kind of some kind of drift uh will
this uh converge to some kind of stable
point and how would it look like would
it be realistic images or avoid well
secondly you you can oh you generate oh
I see and retrain the model from
generated images will it drift to
something that will Mirage you know
frankly I think that's already happening
because often we cannot tell if
something is generated or not
I would venture to say that it's not
going to end well
I think that it's very easy to fall off
that manifold and go with the crazy wind
um and this is why I'm also worried
about you know information on the
internet you know the as as we get more
and more and more synthetic data it it I
think it will be very easy to to go in
the crazy world but how will it look the
Crazy Land what what hey you know it's
just some local minimum is some
somewhere yeah it it could be I think
arbitrary there's been some work on this
recently where you lose the Tails
basically but you what you will see for
example people with six fingers or
things of this kind or you think that
you'll eventually get to a fixed point
of viewer image
no but I will get images that maybe I I
can never see in nature right so
something like that no I think that's
what's gonna happen but I think it's not
going to be one of it I think it's going
to be there's infinitely many local
Minima and I think you're just gonna
fall into one of them randomly that's my
prediction
okay
um okay
five minutes how about I show you
so you wonder okay
I'll give you a choice a paper
a paper with oh wait I can give you a
very quick because you know I I feel
like I should show some of my work but
uh but very quickly this is this is a
paper that's going to be you know
exactly
um the going to be a CPR next week uh
and basically what we are doing here is
we are
uh instead of generating images we're
editing images we're taking a real image
and then we are giving it the prompt is
uh English language text that is an
editing instruction so instead of saying
what should be there we say
swamp sunflowers for Roses or what would
it look like if it were snowing okay
um
so and the idea here is really
if if we had
the training data this would be a
trivial supervised learning problem well
not maybe vegetable but with with modern
diffusion or you know other generative
models it's fine right if we had
input image output image and the text
string
just throw it into the machinery and
just crank crank crank crank crank way
two weeks and it's done okay and pay a
lot of money to Amazon
um but
we don't have that data set that does
not does not exist so really this paper
is really all about how do we get to the
easy part how do we prepare the data
so that we can then hit the crank
do not have supervisors we don't
we don't have that data
okay
once once we get this data everything's
easy so the question is how do you get
the data yes
um to maybe not be enough data like that
but there's plenty of data matching that
format on Photoshop forums yeah so I
mean when we talk about you know these
generative models yeah
you know hundreds or even thousands is
not going to cut it it's it needs to be
you know a couple of waters of ideas
yeah we we thought about this but yeah
it was no nowhere near enough and it's
also not not General enough because
Photoshop forms only shows things that
photoshop can do and this is not really
something that a Photoshop can do well
the latest Photoshop that came out last
week that is true at that yeah okay I'm
not going to say but because some of my
former students are are actually in you
know in charge of that project but yours
is better no no no ours is earlier
um anyway
I guess these clip for this
guess number two
I don't have a guest member okay what's
the most important what's okay I think
it's already here is it no yeah
we use GPT
okay so what what and again this is
actually all my my wonderful students
and and put you in the postdoc chairman
Alex who who came up with this this very
clever trick they created some training
data by hand
literally like you know a few hundred
examples input
image descriptor output image descriptor
and the edit that would go from input
out okay here there's no images this is
just text they just made up or I think
they actually they took an input caption
from from a data set like that uh you
know a line or something and then they
they say okay let's let's edit it and
then write out what it would be as an
output okay so they wrote a few hundred
of those and then they said okay gpt3
0.5
continue the pattern give me more of
these sticks and gpt3 complied and just
produced
a whole bunch of uh
of more available the animation is going
to be very slow uh but yeah
so
is it sufficient to just give input and
output and then GPT can already solve
for the edit line
um they felt that
they wanted to you know again
teaching by example is always better
than uh than them trying to explain
something in a more higher level thing
they've wanted to have the feel of a
kind of image edit and I think I think
they I think they tried this and gbd did
not really get the instructions that
would be that would sound right but you
know this is a little bit of fine too
this is just a little bit of example
it's like you know a few hundred of it
yes gpe is unaware of the image
generation model that will uh will be
this is just you know you you know we
opened up a window and they just
start typing and I imagine that you
would feel you would generate images
using these prompts and uh do you
actually know that it will look like uh
what you asked for or okay it's coming
okay so this is this is now we have
the text
right we have the the triplets
The Triplets of the text so again these
are the handwritten ones and this is the
generalization the GPT you can produce
given
uh input captions that we just stole
from my image data set we are not again
not looking at images though it's just
the text like the text tricks okay and
some of them are actually nonsensical
some of them did not work out they try
to filter them out and then it turns out
that actually keeping them as is is fine
in fact it was a little bit better if
you don't filter anything because more
data is better apparently even if it's
garbage
um but then how do we connect this to to
two images well there is a recent paper
called prompt to prompt and the the that
paper is able to generate new synthetic
images
with related prompts that are themselves
related
so you give it two prompts that are
similar but maybe with one thing changed
and they are able to generate images
that are released so this is these are
not real images they're a synthesized
but there is a relationship between them
that is exactly the relationship that we
want okay
so now we have all our all our induction
are all because we are using GPT to
produce from the input captures the
output caption and the edit
okay then we are using the input and the
output captions into prompt to prompt to
give us two images that is going to be
the input image and the outwards
and now we have our triplet
and now we are ready for some supervised
learning because we have the input image
we have the output image and we have the
the editing prompt and from now on this
is this is easy peasy it's done okay and
and here is an example make this a
grocery store
uh no you can you can kind of did do
multiple edits uh you know you have
different diversity uh
you can generalize to high-res
put it in outer space
and humans to change humans into robots
uh you know you can chain the edits
together
this is really my main contribution to
this whole Endeavor is is this one
figure that I'm very proud of
um I'm particularly excited about how
the the call their sculptures worked out
but I think also the claymation is
pretty nice too
um
uh
hallucinate some 3D
it's the you know it's very interesting
it's it's uh that you know
biases are not just in in in the text
they're definitely also in the images
uh but but it's it's it's kind of it's
kind of cool and of course it's not
going to do magic for you uh it's uh
um you know you cannot it cannot change
it you know the the the layout of the
image has to stay the same so it cannot
zoom in or it cannot like swap these
people and actually the language is the
weakest link here because the language
is uh
is you know Kohler color the type blue
it the time the blue are actually not
binded together although there is now
work that's trying to improve that okay
um and uh just a little example we can
also do this for for 3D scenes using
Nerfs where we can just edit uh edit the
contact and context in in that okay I
think I will end here so let's jump to
the conclusion
and the conclusion is really we should
start to give data it's due crit even
though
it hurts us and our our scientific Pride
but I think it's it it's going to be
good for us long term
yes data is necessary and I think a lot
of data will be necessary but it's not
sufficient there's still going to be
space and an opportunity for the Flights
of Fancy and the creativity and the and
the and the and the human spirit so so I
think I think we'll be fine and we'll
have plenty of fun things to work on for
years to come thank you
foreign
and it's really impressive and it I
think it goes beyond just like
I mean impressionistically really
captures his you know his his style and
um you know I I I played with stable
diffusioni had what total of 200
paintings
um and so so what's your take on on that
like is is you know is I mean data data
training is huge but like you have this
like few shot cases do you think that
the kind of other styles that are well
represented contribute to the ability of
extrapolating from you know a style that
is very whispersed yeah no good question
um by the way the the the this last
paper I we have a uh we have a demo
online and anyone could just go in and
play with it yourself so you know you
can try it yourself my
experience has not been so I I I I you
know some of my favorite uh painters are
uh uh Gustav kaibot and uh and um
and um uh Hopper and
they're both you know light is an
important thing there and it's I I I I
did not feel like wow it's it's really
capturing it but I think
well you know even stepping back a
little bit farther if you want to think
about it in terms of you know art like
for me there is there is Art and then
there is
uh Artisan you know the artisan
an artist are kind of they have very
different objectives Artisan is
is trying to get something that that
looks beautiful
the artist is trying for something new
and so I feel that
even even though there is some sort of
like a style of modeliani
I feel like every time madridyani was
trying for something new he was not
trying to kind of replicate himself he
was trying you know and it's kind of
like the you know the the malevich is
black square right the point of the
black square is that nobody has done it
before
it does not make sense the second black
square is already yeah not not that
exciting right I think I think that
this is really what where humans are are
are still have have you know plenty of
space you know ahead of computers that
that computers are very good
interpolations but they're not very good
at
at moving forward and and kind of
expanding the boundaries
do something new
yeah
you know I think there's a little bit of
too much hype on on all of this like
it's not magic this instruct for example
um there is this there's this new um
Israeli company where they're like they
have a website where you can say I
forget what it's called but it's like
human or not like basically it's like a
Turing test where you're either talking
to a human or uh or or gbt and uh one of
my students yasi uh showed me it's very
easy to defeat you just ask the other
person give me a random number or say
something random
the computer just cannot do it
just cannot do it you know so I I feel
that is actually not that and not that
easy you know I have worked on
creativity computational creativity so
you know we we try this but it's hard
it's hard yes listen since we're at
Simon so it's a it's a relative question
right because uh I think it was there's
this thing aaronson's Oracle which shows
that if um you can all go to it you
click one of two keys at random and
it'll predict your performance at more
than 75 within I don't know under a
minute if you've gone like this at
random basically yeah so it's a question
of who's uh who's that who's evaluating
or who's asking right well yeah here
it's like human evaluating the the
computer yeah human can can evaluate a
computer and a computer can evaluate
oh yeah that's much easier yeah computer
you know we are very predictable yeah uh
yes so maybe taking a step back to the
machine learning problem so basically
your message is when we have a lot of
data then
very simple stuff works probably the
best or at least it can work we should
try the simple stuff first before we get
our egos too high yes but so the
question is when we don't have a lot of
data like in our case for example by
Acoustics so the data is race cars by
Machine learning standards uh what is
the recipe in this case so you you need
to assume a lot right or you need to do
actually sophisticated fancy algorithms
there is some transfer learning that
seems to work quite well actually
surprisingly well so a little bit of
fine tuning on your data plus a whole
bunch of
other data so there is a there is a work
on on visual uh visual prompting for
analogies that I they didn't have time
to show but what we show there is just a
little bit of the right data can can go
a long way but also you know again to
kind of to channel my dear friend
Antonio travel if you don't have enough
data just try really really hard to get
more data because that is that is the
easiest by far the easiest way
uh and and um you know and you're you're
you're you're whales you know they have
seen or they have heard a lot of data
presumably right
so um
so at least evolutionary they have right
so it seems like you know you if you
want to if we're going to compete with
them then then you should uh you should
get as much data as as possible yeah
okay uh thank you for the next talk my
question is in in this discourse uh what
is the place of like that augmentation
or in general the question is
not all data is equal like
if we double our data set with just
copies
this should not help
uh
if we
double our latest with copies with some
noise does it help
documentation show that sometimes help
can we
synthesize new data that is useful
easy in an easier way than collecting
new data so this is the right right so I
am
a data augmentation camp it's not a big
Camp it's a very small camp but
I feel I I'm I I believe in in
self-supervised learning I don't want
the human bias if I can avoid it and and
data augmentation is human bias you are
kind of assuming oh these are the kind
of changes kind of Transformations that
will or which I expect to happen in the
data well then you are basically only
you know preparing for what you expect
you don't prepare for the things that
you don't expect
um and we have seen that if you can
really deal with a lot of data if you
can take in
huge amounts of data then you don't need
data augmentation
um now you could say well you know I for
this particular problem I don't have
enough data
but I feel like
the reason that I I think that transfer
learning
training on on some data then finding
another data seems to work surprisingly
well is because
of the of the of the nature of our of
our world that our world and the world
of of other animals and maybe even the
world of animals who who live under the
water it's still it's the same phys a
lot of the same physical constraints
apply and so it seems like
if we capture some of those constraints
in in data that maybe is not even that
related
it feels like it should have
and I feel like it should help more than
trying to imagine the kind of
Transformations that you expect should
happen
um so I'm all for just trying to get as
much data as possible even if it's just
a very different data but still real
physical data from our physical world
and see if that if that can help you but
you know if if that still doesn't work
sure you can you can do data
augmentation but I'm I see a brilliant
glorious future when we will never will
not need data documentation
yes so I guess even with really large
amounts of data there's always a problem
of long tail right like you also put
that up on your side and that I guess
cannot be solved with collecting even
more data because then it'll just be a
different set of a different subset of
your data that'll fall under that oh
well the the thing with long tails is
we think
we humans are so good at the long tails
but of course we're only good at the
things that we are know we are good at
there must be so many things that we're
really really terrible at
but we just don't know that we're
terrible at it because we don't notice
it
so I think that
the kind of long tails we are good at
are they are in the what's the opposite
of the long title the fat middle I don't
is there is that yeah but
okay
parts of it are I think in the Philip
middle I think the long tail some very
uh and you know unusual things are still
made up of the more usual things
so I think with the right
compositionality
I think we can kind of map it back into
the into the middle
that's that's my my my feeling is that
if it's really truly only happens once I
think humans are just as bad as anything
else
because you know we're we're pattern
recognizers this this is what we are and
so if the pattern only happened once
there is just no chance
it's just that we are good at kind of
manipulating and warping these patterns
in a way that that we can still
recognize them even when they're hiding
away from us
all right thank you very much that was a
perfect perfect
[Applause]
wow so uh This was um this was a really
inspiring two days of uh of talks we
covered a lot of ground a lot of
disciplines
um a huge thank you first to the
co-organizers to Shafi goldbuster and
Michael bronstein
and to all of you for for just
participating and and really everybody
here really
um added so much to this and um so this
was the decoding non-human Communication
number two because we did the first one
in the pandemic
um so it was online so this is the first
time that this was uh this was an
in-person one and um so we'd like to
sort of announce that we'll do another
one next year
um so we'll do three
um so this is the this will be an
ongoing thing and
um yeah I also just wanted to pass to to
the two co-organizers to say a few last
words
yeah I want to thank everybody for
coming and um I know that um uh the plan
was to have the next one in Boston but I
actually am very inspired by the ahinas
and I think we should have it in Africa
stay a little way but
I'm not completely joking but we'll have
to talk to Danielle Larose about that
um anyway thank you all for coming I
think it was fascinating and um I think
Rob has got a lot of heat on him now
with all the data
acquisition
um is as to all of us so thank you and
Michael
well I will be brief I think it was
wonderful at least I feel that we
learned a lot and uh compared to the
first Workshop which was online in the
midst of the pandemic I think seeing
people in person is completely different
experience so thank you for coming
one last thing we started the conference
um you know um talking about uh Roger
Payne and uh through these last two days
the the word has got out more of um of
the Legacy that he left and I just
wanted to dedicate this conference to uh
to Dr Roger Payne our our senior advisor
of project steady
um a deep friend and and mentor to many
of us and
um as we continue on um he was just two
weeks ago I was with him telling him
about this project and he was he was
hoping to join in on the live stream and
was uh was excited about it and was very
excited that his other very close friend
Diana Reese was coming here and um to
integrate into this so um yeah to Roger
who will continue on with us in memory
as we as we continue on this journey
together so thank you
[Applause]
major things to David was really
organized at all
foreign